avec des amis et de rire.
Reportage Nabi Alexandre
Chartier.
Les soirées humoristiques
En 6 ans, le Bordel comédie
club est devenu une adresse
incontournable en humour au
Québec. Ses soirées affichent
régulièrement complet et
le concept fait des petits.
MICHAEL LARRAGUIBEL
Humoriste
- Moi je trouve que ça pop là.
En ce moment, on part tous nos
projets finalement parce qu'on
veut tous jouer et il y a
beaucoup monde; c'est difficile
de jouer, c'est pour ça que
les gens partent des projet
et il y a des soirées d'humour
quasiment maintenant à tous
les jours et plusieurs fois.
- En effet, les soirées d'humour
se multiplient comme ici
au ComediHa! Club de Ste-Foy.
P-A MÉTHOT, humoriste, animateur
Mercredis Comedy ha! Club
- C'est tellement un beau
laboratoire que c'est vraiment
le fun. Peu importe où t'es
rendu ou à quel stade tu es
rendu dans ta carrière, c'est
le fun de venir faire des comedy
club parce que c'est un petit
bassin d'humoristes, une petite
soirée bien intime.
Tu rencontres d'autres
collègues, tu as un public
qui est là, qui est plus petit
aussi, mais qui écoute, qui est
bien proche de toi. C'est
extraordinaire, ça fait du bien.
En plus, comme une grosse
caresse après avoir pleuré.
- À St-Eustache, Le Patriote
Comedy club ouvrira ses portes
le 22 octobre. Ce concept
anglo-saxon s'implante dans
la belle province, où l'on aime
rire.
DAVE GAUDET, humoriste co-
fondateur Patriote Comédie Club
- On s'inspire beaucoup de New-
York, tu sais les Comedy Club
Style. Fait que, ici c'est
la même affaire avec le mur
de brique et la bouffe finger
food.
- Pour les tenanciers de bars,
comme ceux de la Petite Marche
à Montréal, c'est une occasion
d'attirer de nouveau les gens
dans leurs établissements.
Alors que pour les humoristes,
c'est une occasion d'accroître
leur notoriété et de faire
du réseautage.
OLIVIER FOY
Humoriste
- On connaît pratiquement tout
le monde qui pratique l'art de
la blague à Montréal. On finit
par se recroiser. On s'invite
sur nos show et tout.
Fait qu'il   y a vraiment
un sentiment de communauté.
- Un passage obligé pour
les humoristes de la relève
qui veulent tester leur matériel
et gagner en assurance.
SARA BOULAIS, humoriste,
animatrice soirée humour
- C'est pas le genre de trucs
que tu peux faire tout seul
dans ton salon. Tu sais, ça te
prend vraiment un public pour
interagir, fait qu'on n'a pas
le choix d'avoir des soirées
comme ça; et là, on est vraiment
chanceux, parce qu'à Montréal,
il y a vraiment plein, plein.
À chaque soir, tu peux aller
dans une soirée d'humour.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le public, a l'embarras
du choix. Les soirées d'humour
sont nombreuses et
les humoristes aussi.
VAL BELZIL
Humoriste
- Je pense que l'écrémage
se fait au niveau de la somme
de travail.  Il y a peut-être
des gens que ça décourage et
si, par exemple, en commençant
tu trouves déjà que c'est trop
de travail de jouer trois fois
par semaine et de réécrire
tes gags, c'est peut-être pas
une métier qui est pour toi.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Après une année éprouvante,
toutes ces soirées d'humour
permettent de retrouver
le sourire.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
♪